[Música]
o candidato é obrigado
o centro é eu resolvi é começar a que
esta conversa o ocean lançou este
desafio trazer uns um erro que está
embarcado num ataque do melhor livro que
lembram mas entretanto não está no
mercado é que os processos e o confesso
que gosto muito talento mas não gosto
dos livros que já o wii um exemplar chão
e por isso trouxe sexto livro que se
chama ganz james tinham armas germes e
as do irã que é um livro é é um dos mais
fascinantes que já dura mais de dez anos
e trata é da questão mais importante
para os economistas que é porque há
países ricos porque a países pobres
porque alguns países que eram pobres e
se tornaram ricos e ficar porque há
países que não conseguem sair da
armadilha da pobreza é um livro que
trata no principal problema econômico
mas foi escrito por um biólogo melhor
que nós conseguimos é facto ter um
escritor o próprio lyon quando este
livro é a grande sensação que foi um
deslumbramento que eu tentei ler este
livro fez uma regular o deslumbramento
que o cultivo quando tinha 12 anos
venceu na figueira da foz e descobrir
enciclopédia luso-brasileira
é eu desde que entrei na primária de
sempre atrás do livro não tem muitos
jogos em casa mas que estão sempre muito
ruim brasil de sempre atrás dos livros é
tentava dizer que estava virou centro na
primária é biblioteca em 2011 uma tábua
com livros em símios todos vão acontecer
até a escola tinha é a fundação calouste
gulbenkien douro queremos que o voo era
por isso tento sempre dar 91 vivida por
essa por essa pergunta a equipe grande
mas pode vencer na figueira da foz eu
tenho uma biblioteca fantástica
então quero jogar futebol
ficar chato na biblioteca é um livro
enciclopédia luso-brasileira seu
gravador enciclopédia é destaque naquela
altura é é que foi a mais 30 anos quando
se cria saber coisas tenha curiosidade
era preciso que os gastos em uma série
de fatores como conseguir entrar numa
biblioteca com uma biblioteca da escola
secundária joaquim carvalho na figueira
da foz que era uma chantagem que já
naquela altura que hoje lembra um igual
e eu acho consiga avaliar uma luta que
se aquilo era uma flip muita coisa
naquela altura no início dos anos 80
hoje em dia não é assim o no doubt uma
forma extraordinária é e hoje é hoje de
facto para a maior parte das pessoas é
ignorância é uma escolha tão ignorante
escolheram ser grande na sua maioria
claro que a axé sonhos de uma maneira
geral as pessoas não querem saber as
coisas é porque não tomam a iniciativa
de espreitar as coisas estão estão em
washington e pela efe dois estão aí
jornais estão aí o filme por aí visto
hoje é essa
nos anos 80 os livros é também professor
universitário absu universitário eu
costumo eu costumo viver
costumo dizer era e lembrar a mim
próprio e lembrar os outros que um dos
grandes privilégios e professora
universitária
entretanto que houve aqui nesta são e
cujo lema é deixar a porta aberta um dos
grandes privilégios dos universitária
por deixar a porta é uma coisa
fantástica em casa do negócio fazer é se
eu achar a porta está sozinho a pensar
de escrever é é coisa que não dá mais
prazer na vida
eu gosto de lembrar sempre isso o maior
privilégio pessoa que solicitar é fechar
a porta mas claro que depôs o obrigou a
deixar entrar coisas é ótima bola para
criar compartilhar coisas más
é eu só achei que é preciso ter para nos
juntarmos e podemos partilhar preciso de
coisas pra isso é muito importante o
xará porta mas voltando ao tema do livro
é porque a pessoa rica países pobres
portugal vive numa fase muito complicada
portugal está e não sei se vocês têm
essa essa pressão mas a economia
portuguesa no ano de 2010 a isso vai
produzir basicamente o mesmo que
produziu no ano 2000 seja 15 anos depois
outras seis anos depois o país está em
comparavelmente melhor do ponto de vista
das infra estruturas estradas portos com
boys aeroportos edifícios das
universidades dos hospitais
as pessoas são incomparavelmente mais
bem informadas
temos as gerações mais bem informadas de
sempre
no entanto está tudo na mesma com a
minha produção exatamente a mesma coisa
e esse é o paradoxo que há uns anos
minha culpa e tentar perceber como é que
isso é possível
assim as infra estruturas são melhores
se os materiais são melhores se as
pessoas são melhores porque a combinação
dessas duas dois fatores produção como
nós temos da economia no resultado dava
melhor
não sabemos se estamos na mesma e essa é
pra mim é é grande questão é a grande
questão é a grande questão é a grande
questão portugal neste momento enfrenta
e sobretudo é interessante lembrar ao no
momento em que nós vivemos mais uma
revolução tecnológica
o mundo é está a motivar é um passou a
um ritmo cada vez mais na flor há também
um centro econômico jovens trazem
economia portuguesa nuno palma que foi
construído recentemente em que conclui
em 1801 foi industrial quando o policial
estava a começar a portugal era mais
rico que amanhã em 1800 do mundo
começaram a mudar muito depressa
nós estávamos na linha da frente mas
quando o mundo como foi mudar muito
depressa mas não conseguiu
acompanharam ver com mudança no mundo
nós não conseguimos acompanhar a
evolução da máquina a vapor
nós não conseguimos acompanhar a a
assunção é da galáxia do automóvel ea
grande questão que se coloca agora será
que agora vamos conseguir acompanhar
esta nova revolução digital
será que vamos ter pela lava para isso
essa é grande e essa é a grande questão
é e que de facto do livro se lados ocupa
um lugar central para nós podermos
acompanhar cada vez mais é uma revolução
tecnológica
nós temos pelas universidades na linha
da frente e temos pelas universidades
muito próximas da empresa e as guias e
as empresas muito próximas das das
universidades e de facto é de facto é
uma das funções mais importantes que
aconteceram
é nos últimos anos em portugal foi uma
maior presença das universidades nas
empresas nas universidades há mais de
dez anos as empresas apareciam de vez em
quando nas universidades hoje em dia
essas empresas e outras organizações da
cidade estão diariamente nas
universidades estão nas universidades
seja nos seus órgãos de gestão
só houve uma transformação institucional
que o novo regime jurídico das
instituições do ensino superior que
obrigaram é que nos órgãos de governação
das universidades tivessem pessoas fora
da universidade e por isso é o ministro
mariano gago impôs que vai dentro das
universidades
tivesse a sociedade essa é uma dimensão
mas hoje as empresas estão também dentro
das necessidades de muitas maneiras
parte com essa informação
nós confirmamos os currículos ouvimos os
empresários é através do programa de
estágio é em programas de investigação e
desenvolvimento em com parcerias entre
universidades e empresas em que é é é
que os portugueses incluindo aquela que
o potencial do estado nem isso tem se
tem isso tem se destacado é uma qualquer
maneira isso ainda é pouco
isso ainda é pouco se nós olharmos para
aquilo que acontece por exemplo é
naquelas que são as
os grandes exemplos a interação entre
empresas e universidades nos lembramos
da estrutura das universidades de
moçambique sônicas lembramos por exemplo
é o da universidade stanford disse lula
quando ela nós pensarmos nisso pensamos
naquilo que existe na europa existe fora
do mundo com vossa acção nem nos anos 50
o diretor do departamento de engenharia
foi até a irmã estava não era novidade
está no fórum civil que os 700 hectares
do macho que estavam ao lado da
universidade não ser cativadas para que
os investigadores as pessoas pudessem
criar lá as suas empresas e 12 as
tecnologias das universidades que a
chegada não está distante for para gerar
empresas tecnológicas ea partir daí
seria possível depois que as pessoas das
empresas participassem nas atividades da
universidade dando boas também e
interagindo com os investigadores é isso
foi criado nos anos 50 nos estados
unidos é se olharem pra europa e em
portugal em particular a esses campos
enormes com parque de ciência e
tecnologia ao lado das universidades é
uma coisa que não existe e não existe
porque não existe porque se é europa tem
uma história é uma história da mesma
maneira que nós não conseguimos ter
centros comerciais com a dimensão que os
estados unidos têm por termos tantos
históricos nas cidades também as
universidades foram criei foram sendo
criadas dentro de uma malha urbana que
já existia e foram sendo criadas por
paus e por isso é quase todas as
universidades portuguesas não são todas
ou quase todas na europa está o traço
comum às universidades tenham múltiplo
lars é muito mais difícil ou seja aquela
idéia de termos empresas e hoje
universidades juntas fica muito mais
difícil confira fica muito mais difícil
conseguir o que é certo e por que por
que mesmo dentro das legislativas
há muitas culturas ora se é é que os
grandes campos é ela e somente conseguem
pensamento juntará os vários
departamentos que interagem uns com os
outros e que
e que geram conhecimentos e valores
estão próximos das empresas
nós na europa e em particular em
portugal às vezes nem tratamentos
conseguiu se comunicar bem porque
estamos afastados uns dos outros
imagina depois com as empresas não estou
a dizer que isso é uma atitude que
mostram que isto tem um impacto mas como
costumo dizer não vale a pena pensar
nisso nós não vamos conversar ver as
condições em que trabalhamos mas não
vale a pena pensar agora vamos fazer a
instalações universitárias vamos
trabalhar tudo que está à frente vamos
construir tudo novo
não é assim que as coisas funcionam nós
vamos construir a partir daquilo que
existe e por isso com esta organização
que nós temos que é multipolar em quetta
que nós não estamos fisicamente próximos
uns dos outros como é que nós
conseguimos que as universidades e as
empresas estão cada vez mais próximas
entretanto começar por dizer que nos
dias de hoje é o próximo da fila que não
tem mais importância e quinhentos anos
50 já forma estarão os próximos e testar
nos afastar fisicamente
o processo é essa é para mim é para mim
um dos primeiros grandes desafios é como
é que nós como é que nós nas
universidades conseguiram estar próximos
consigo estar próximos de assinar
próximos das empresas do tal forma que
mesmo que nós fizemos é que anunciamos
desing fisicamente quando uma empresa
tem um problema empresa lembra que a
solução pode estar na universidade
esse é o grande desafio
ou seja nós vamos ter que ter o
conhecimento na universidade onde há
pouco podemos partilhar nós temos que
ter o conhecimento e precisam estar na
fronteira do conhecimento
esse é um primeiro a primeira dimensão e
por isso e quando é preciso fechar a
porta uma notória do gabinete porque
temos que estar na fronteira do
conhecimento
depois é como é que o parque anos então
aí entra uma doença muito importante é
que nós comunicamos consiste na
legislação isso eu gostava do meu começo
é é observar com o aparecimento da
internet é e como foram em muitas
páginas
nessas universidades que comunicam com
silas é é até há muito pouco tempo as
páginas das universidades eram feitas
para que a sociedade se comunicassem
umas com as outras
ou seja um determinado para também
crianças afirmaram que mostrar o que sei
fazer mas queria mostrar o que sabem
fazer aos seus parte das outras
universidades e por isso os académicos
transmitem essa mensagem
o que é que o que eu sei fazer
fazem para os seus passos ainda hoje
esta é a cultura dominante há uns 12
anos mais ou menos não vou um pouco
porque as notícias começaram a ter
dificuldades em conseguir encher os
cursos
então começaram a competir por alunos e
começaram a ter conteúdos direcionados
aos alunos e aos pais não são as
empresas continua a haver muito pouco
quem quiser saber o que é que vai fazer
tenham problemas consegue essa função
está é não negociar mais próxima ou ou
não tão próxima é as empresas ou terem
um contacto e tem lá imensos contactos
há muito há muitos projetos com empresas
mas é muito difícil alguém que já não
está no meio entrar numa entanto não
sabe qual o número foi para onde é que o
igor com quem é que eu falo
e isto poderá sim o que é que está um
problema hoje em dia também também me
pergunto como é que são problemas mas
quando eu procuro motivar as pessoas
para escreverem sobre aquilo que fazem
uma linguagem que é é cível para alguém
que não acabei me extremamente difícil
é extremamente difícil pois não tem essa
dificuldade vamos falar um exemplo as
pessoas universitários gostam de se
apresentar como professor auxiliar com
agregação professor associado com
agregação
isto é uma linguagem que regras não
interessa absolutamente nada as pessoas
pessoas querem saber é natural que se
esforçavam que adotou segundo a
especialista em que as pessoas querem
saber de facto essa é uma informação é
uma informação que normalmente é nas
universidades se procurarem isto não é
só em portugal está muito né
copa essa informação não está disponível
alguma forma sistemática é para para
para as universidades e por isso nós
temos temos que mudar isso é o cidadão
sac um magnífico largo mas eu acho que
temos os instrumentos todos próximo para
o que nós temos que esperar o que temos
que fazer para mudar isso e aqui o
expresso extremamente simples mas como
dizia isso implica mudar a forma como as
pessoas olham para as coisas se as
pessoas têm que deixar de olhar para
aquilo que fazem é simplesmente é
comparando com as outras universidades
algum tipo de dor e facto olharem mais
para as empresas é e eu acho que os
exemplos que existem podem ser sincero
sentimento usá-los para isso
este aspecto nós partiram sempre a
mudança daquilo que existe é tendo em
conta pois até cogitado explicou para
poder mudar as coisas
é é muito importante é um 10 anos
descobriu se que a nazaré
há uma onda enorme porque é uma onda
fantástica que colocou nazaré com o
portugal é nuno
qualquer um sabe o que é legal é aquela
onde está há milhares de anos
aquela onda instalar em portugal terá
possível claro que enquanto não observa
não servia para nada na minha prancha
sonda não servia para nada
entretanto apareceram as pranchas já há
muitas muitas décadas ea honda continuou
a em novembro chega aos 30 metros em
dezembro é e continuamos a não ter essas
festas lá alguém dizer nível mas como é
que ninguém descobriu a onda eu dizia
olha só por só poder ser safar véu
quando apareceram as motas de água série
numa porque o papel-moeda daquelas taxas
por uma mota poderosa e por isso nós
temos aqui duas coisas primeiro se
calhar podemos ter descoberto a onda
mais chuva mas ela também só passou a
ser a
onda para sérgio quando apareceram as
motas permitiram colocar os surfistas a
segunda onda e porque é que nós temos
nós temos que olhar para os nossos
recursos para as nossas ondas
há muito mais longas como ondas da
nazaré integral e temos que saber que
nós combinamos isso com a tecnologia é e
esta ligação fato recursos que nós temos
entre aquilo que é a nossa economia
aquilo que que a tecnologia disponível
ea forma como nós olhamos para essa
combinação de tecnologia como eu dei a
pouco nós temos melhores grande
infraestrutura nós temos melhores
pessoas mas todos nós temos que saber
como é que conseguimos combinar essas
infra-estruturas e essas pessoas de
forma melhor para conseguirmos produzir
mais é gerar mais riqueza e distribuir
lá é forma que todos possamos viver
melhor e prosa já conheço é santo e
vibro teve com ondas
[Aplausos]
[Música]